[Music]
you are running to build a kenya
of hope and opportunity one big kenyan
tribe
and i want to tell the people of kenya
enough is enough
and freedom is coming
[Music]
raila odinga support this is the closest
i can state it is you feel that sort of
love at a football match he does have
die hard fanatics who would even you
know if he was going to appear somewhere
they would make sure that they get a
front row seat
he's
someone who's first generation
into politics and able to rise from
being a youth leader to a minister to a
deputy president now going for president
in such a very short time frame these
are things that can take decades
there was a point where
they were sort of on the same side but
where we began to see a rift
was after
the 2018 handshake things really began
to change between the two of them
because there was clearly a shift where
the president was no longer
supportive to his deputy
and he was very supportive to ray
laudinga and he sort of became a third
will
and
losing his influence losing
in terms of what he was able to do the
committees that he could control
[Music]
the main challenges for the next
president is going to be
looking at the economy
we are living in a time where the high
cost of living is really affecting us
and so food is also just too expensive
so people want somebody who is going to
do what they can immediately to reduce
those costs and they won't care how so
it's going to be someone of action and
quick action
[Music]
if there's disagreements there's going
to be a court case i believe that i
think we have normalized
taking issues to court and petitioning
the court
rather than going to the streets and
demonstrating i think that's a step in
the right direction
[Music]